hey guys it's alex welcome back to my
apartment we're all spending more time
at home and it's even more important now
to keep ample snacks around your house
and keeping snacks around is almost as
important as doing my laundry i
definitely snack more than i do my
laundry now i also know that with this
extra time at home it's really easy to
snack all day and have some trouble
keeping things healthy in comes granola
it's versatile it's customizable it's
easy to make there's really no going
wrong all right let's get to it it's
granola time
[Music]
for the base as with most granolas i am
using rolled oats i'm also going to be
adding some almonds now you can use
whatever nuts you have on hand walnuts
pecans peanuts would work great but
almonds are what i have we're also going
to be using smooth peanut butter if you
don't have smooth peanut butter you can
use crunchy peanut butter you could use
almond butter the options are endless
we'll also be using some coconut oil
coconut oil is great because it will act
as almost like a glue keeping everything
together for sweetness i'm going to be
using maple syrup because this is what i
have on hand if you don't have maple
syrup you can also use honey or agave or
any kind of sweetener finally for flavor
we're going to be adding salt cinnamon
and vanilla and that's it all right i'm
getting snacky already so let's get
rolling on this granola
all right so i have my three cups of
rolled oats in my bowl to that i'm gonna
add my half a cup of almonds again you
can use whatever kind of nut you have on
hand you could also swap out
nuts for dried fruit or
seeds seeds work great here too my
teaspoon of cinnamon cinnamon is also
great because not only is it so
flavorful but it's super good for you
too it rubs your metabolism
and you know i could use all the help i
can get nowadays
all right so i'm gonna leave our oats
alone for now and move over to the stove
where i have a third of a cup of smooth
peanut butter again you can use whatever
kind of peanut butter you want crunchy
smooth using the peanut butter here will
just give us a ton of flavor in the
final result and i just really love
peanut butter so
that's what i'm doing to this i'm going
to add three tablespoons of coconut oil
so i'm over medium heat and i'm just
kind of melting this all down into a
nice sauce next is our maple syrup
a teaspoon of salt
the salt is really nice here not only
for flavor but also to bring out the
other notes of sweetness in the granola
and lastly two teaspoons of vanilla
ugh i love vanilla so much
sometimes i wear as like a perfume
my cheap
so you definitely could do this in the
microwave
but i actually don't have a microwave it
exploded once long story
so i'm doing this over the stove but it
will work just the same so it's fairly
fast i just needed to melt it down but
we're good so now i'm just gonna pour
our delicious peanut buttery sauce all
over our prepared oats
oh that looks so good it also smells
amazing if i wasn't snacky before i am
now
what would be the equivalent of like
hangry for snacking
like snangri
i'm just angry
okay so now i'm just gonna mix this all
up it looks so good
i wanna make sure all the oats are
covered in our peanut butter sauce
mixture be careful because there's some
pockets underneath so you wanna really
stir this pretty well no oat left behind
all right i've got a greased baking
sheet right here you can also use
parchment paper if you have that at home
i'm just gonna pour our granola mixture
right onto it
and spread it out evenly
[Music]
and now i'm going to bake this at 325
degrees for about 25 minutes and then
we'll check on it and add some more fun
stuff
[Music]
all right it's been about 25 minutes i'm
gonna check on our granola and by the
way i cannot even begin to describe how
good it smells in my apartment right now
looks so nice and golden and toasty so
granola comes in many different kind of
like shapes if you want to chunk your
granola with like bigger pieces in it
you're not going to want to stir it too
much here but if you want a looser
granola where all the pieces are more
broken up then you can stir it more
shake around
just going to break some of it up next
i'm going to add some unsweetened
coconut flakes if you don't have coconut
flakes you can add shredded coconut if
you don't have either of those then you
can skip it all together the reason i'm
adding it now is because the coconut
toasts up really quick and then we're
just gonna bake it a little bit more so
that the coconut toasts up but doesn't
burn and one last little stir
and back in the oven we go i'm gonna be
baking this again at 325 for another
like five minutes but you want to be
checking on this just to make sure it
doesn't burn because it can burn quickly
it's beautiful
again smells so good in here so as you
can see the coconut has got some color
on it it's a little toasty and roasty
all right our granola has cooled time
for the final ingredient we've saved the
best for last i'm adding some chocolate
chips of course we're adding it now that
it's cooled so that they don't melt all
over the place
not all granola has to have chocolate
chips but you know what i figured we
could all use a little chocolate
nowadays am i right
so just spread that around
and that's it all right our granola is
done how easy was that i swear once you
start making your own homemade granola
there is no going back to the
store-bought stuff and best part is you
can store this granola for up to a month
at room temperature in an airtight
container i usually store my granola in
a big mason jar with a lid on my
countertop so it's ready to go anytime i
need a snack let's try it
that is so good you've got some bigger
pieces in there and also the smaller
pieces and the chocolate don't forget
the chocolate
all right well i hope you enjoyed this
recipe if you want me to make anything
else let me know and i'll catch you guys
next time
it's snack time
oh yes
[Music]
[Applause]
you